says says
[Music]
damn and a wad of bills doesn't
make you rich either I'm talking clue Thank
goodness it's not a crime we are abnormal bro
don't go overboard crime I feel bigger
than my reference I like to [ __ ] an
intelligent [ __ ] I have a great future
I  said a Seer who comes in silver
and everything that I have in my mind that
they are fecas of that I am aware I
laugh listening to it I know that I lie I
come from the future and I have it in mind
counting the faces of the presidents on
papers my letters  It causes you to
misplace your papers. I feel like Maradona
and Pelé. I read Los Giles and my energy
repels it. I don't believe, [ __ ], that you
reach your levels. I don't even manage the
fabric anymore. It handles itself. Nothing intelligent. I take
care of the ozone layer. Don't
try here.  You know how we are, I have
achieved so much.
I know you like my lifestyle,
but if you get involved, I want to know well that there
is no way out. The master will leave everything with
saliva and let's go all the way up.
Give me the clue, I'm with a quijo.
the big [ __ ], I have that I don't know what
people like, we've been
leading the charge for several years now, don't deal with
us, brute force falls on you. Ah, I
'm doing it cool, my bad, if you
feel overwhelmed, I'm still Money zero
tied up, I'm going with  my path with what is mine gets you
tied Hey yes, as I am the one
noted and increasingly connoted Hey
Pass me the cuco I want to be angry Hey
listen to the Flow but have you noticed it